comme inapte à la vie est belle et je
suis très heureux aujourd'hui
enghien dû virer ce que serait ma c'est
moi et de mes forces
olala la vie n'est plus belle et je ne
suis pas heureux quoi que dites-vous en
rien rien pourquoi ne vous inquiétez pas
j'ai compris je ne viens pas vous
cherchez vous m'appellerez pas non plus
vous prend canard en sucre ni votre
petit lapin bleu c'est promis bon alors
savoir la vie est belle et celui de
nouveaux éléments nous lie à non non non
mais t'es vous achevez encore chaque
fois que je vous serre la main vous mme
écrasé les doigts
c'est vrai que je n'aime pas les
poignées de même ce n'est pas grave je
ne vous en veux pas bon bah tant mieux
alors casimir je vais être direct
je suis venu vous voir moi j'ai besoin
que vous me rendiez un service un vrai
service un grand service j'ai beaucoup
entendu parler de votre intelligence et
votre faculté de travail
vous êtes turc a ces deux mois que vous
avez entendu parler
aucun doute n'essayez pas de jouer les
modestes moi modeste
si françois et juillet entendez ça bon
alors quel est le genre de service que
vous voulez que je vous rends remercie
je savais que je pouvais compter sur
votre aide sinon nous la main c'est
entendu
ah ouais bon excusez moi mais je vous
dis toujours que vous avez horreur des
poignées de main molle ce n'est pas très
grave mais cela prouve simplement que
vous n'avez pas beaucoup de mémoire en
route ça n'enlève rien à usage de votre
intelligence ce n'est pas un usage de
mon intelligence qui m'inquiète c'est l'
usage de mes droits
désolé mais venons-en à mon service je
suis chargé d'un travail très important
que je ne peux malheureusement mener à
bien toute seule c'est pourquoi j'ai
pensé à un travail très important
oui je de se charger de trouver combien
d'espèces de fruits il y a dans l'île
établir la liste complète
c'est très facile ça pour moi non pour
prendre je les retire
c'est quoi exactement la commandite vous
le vertige
ouais le vertige c'est la peur du vide
vous allez comprendre
pour cueillir certains fruits qui sont
dans les arbres il faut monter à une
échelle et moi dès que j'ai gravi quatre
échelons je n'ose plus regarder le sol
j'ai l'impression que les chefs
tremblent et que je vais tomber
c'est ça le vertige aux c'est pourquoi
j'ai pensé à vous
vous n'avez pas peur de monter une
échelle or non pas du tout moi je n'ai
peur de rien ou presque rien bravo et
merci
alors je vais vous confier une copie de
la liste peu des fouilles que je dois
ramasser
vous vous occupez des fouilles pour
lesquels il faut une échelle et moi je
ramasse tous les autres c'est entendu
vous pouvez compter sur moi ap ap les
voilà au revoir mademoiselle futur va
bon
[Musique]
casimir east side tu penses ah non non
je me demandais où je pourrais bien
trouver une échelle une échelle et
pourquoi faire plaisir mais parce que je
dois cueillir des fraises
mon voeu que j'aime il ne faut pas
d'échelle pour cueillir des fraises
tu es sûr évidemment on écoute je
préfère quand même demandé aux enfants
si tu veux kazim et les enfants venez
m'aider
venez venez vite nous allons faire un
jeu avec casimir côté sabine nous
écoutons les images où je vous explique
un gel à toute une liste de fruits il ya
des fruits colorés on doit accueillir
avec une échelle c'est à dire des fruits
qui poussent sur les arbres et des
fruits que l'on peut ramasser sans
échelle alors je voudrais que vous
m'aidiez vous voulez bien moyen corps et
aussi chez alors je commence un jeu doit
amasser dépêcha il faut une échelle pour
les pêches
oui meriam alors ça penche sur les
arbres bon d'accord des myrtilles jour
des arbres patrick a raison il ne faut
pas d'échelle pour cueillir les
myrtilles
non ça c'est au sort à peu près c'est
pas très haut donc pas d'échelle ensuite
la colorimétrie je ne m'en occupe pas
des cassis bon d'accord pas d'échelle
alors pas l'egypte et remet à jour les
arbres des noix de coco dans des arbres
alors d'accord c'est assez haut
d'ailleurs et céder des murs
tu as raison patrick à cette hauteur sur
des petits arbustes
ah oui comme si les petits fruits
presque noir verna mondial dans la
campagne on se met sur ma liste il y a
aussi des noix des noirs noirs
[Musique]
il faut une échelle sa poule mais vous
connaissez l'expression gaulle et les
noix c'est dire on prend une gaule et on
les fait tomber en tapant comme c'est
d'accord d'accord des hameaux dans les
armes dans les arts du monde et la
technique dans les arbres bon des
framboises non ça c'est bon
alors vous êtes tous d'accord qu pas
d'échelle pas des chaînons d'accord des
oranges
ah oui mais pas toujours les consignes à
certains étrangers qui sont comme ça bon
même vous vous pouvez les attraper des
poires oui quoi bon là tout le monde est
d'accord est bonne le chef il ya les
deux ensuite les sourires des cieux
qu'est ce que c'est bon bon enfin celles
qui sont en haut il faut une échelle bon
et certaines des branches certaines des
branches retombe à notre portée d'accord
des prunes oeuvre une des petites brunes
d'un continent une échelle pour amasser
les prunes les gérer derniers fruits les
groseilles à maquereau les groseilles à
maquereau échelle ou pas d'échelle mais
dis moi enfin françois pas d'échelle
enfin des leurs ils ont décrit des
groseilles à maquereau alors c'est un
poisson ou c'est un fruit
mais enfin écoutez toute façon je me
dépêche je vais chercher mon échelle 1
les enfants vous savez ce que c'est que
des conseils et pourquoi on les appelle
les groseilles à maquereau et bien
saviez d'une très vieille recette
autrefois on a comme modèle et macro les
poissons justement avec ce genre de
groseilles
[Musique]
vous pensez qu'il y en ait encore trop
longtemps ça je ne peux rien vous dire
il est parti il y un long moment déjà à
la recherche d'une échelle heureusement
qu'il a accepté de m'aider
le voici il a l'air bien que
mademoiselle futé vous êtes déjà là oui
j'ai terminé vous à moi ça va j'ai eu un
petit problème je n'ai pas trouvé
d'échelle mais casimir que fais-tu avec
cette canne à pêche et bien comme je
n'ai pas trouvé d'échelle pour ramasser
les noix et les poires
j'ai apporté ma canne à pêche avec ça je
pourrais au moins un attrapé des
groseilles à maquereau
[Musique]